one of the next things that's going to
come down is when you start slashing and
burning when you when you have to cut
back and when I get at the situations
when I look at companies you always have
to be concerned about the human nature
of people I mean people need jobs people
need to you know survive
so you have responsibilities to your
shareholders your responsibilities to
your the people who work for you but you
also have responsibilities to you know
the you know General economic
environment welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of fam Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
C-Tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with my friend Stephen
gerbsman nationally recognized crisis
turnaround CEO restructuring
professional and private investment
banker who has been involved in
maximizing Enterprise Value stakeholder
and shareholder value in a broad variety
of Industries he has worked with the
wide spectrum of senior and Junior
lenders bondholder groups venture
capital and private Equity sources
private investors and institutional
groups he has acted in the capacity of
Crisis turnaround CEO Chief
restructuring officer crisis consultant
private investment banker examiner for
the office of the United States trustee
a member of the board of directors of
various companies an advisor to
stakeholder groups Mr gerbsman has over
54 years of Senior Management Marketing
sales and finance experience and has
been involved in a various business and
investment Ventures as an officer
director consultant and investor both in
the US and internationally
Stephen gerbesman welcome to 20 minute
leaders again thank you so much for
being here how are you I am well and
you're in a Tel Aviv as I understand yes
I am and it's really really great to
have you here with me we have such a an
awesome conversation last time and I
look forward to continuing I believe it
was nearly a year and a half ago and so
a very timely
with all the different crazy things that
are happening in the markets and uh and
all the different uh you know these last
few years have been so uh incredible
around me you know from so many
different perspectives on on what's been
happening with companies and so I'm
excited to talk to you today about like
why some companies succeed and some fail
and end ultimately a little bit about
the Black Swan so so Stephen you know
take it away why in your opinion do
companies succeed companies fail
you know it's real simple there are
three words cash cash and cash there are
other issues that affect that but let me
take you back in a second from strategic
stuff uh we've been in business 40 years
and you know I always uh like to say the
more things change the more they remain
the same
you had a cycle in 1980 you had a cycle
in 1989 92 98 2001 2008 2014 all these
Cycles were pressured uh by various
economic situations
um in relationship to the stock market
to the FED uh and it always revolves
around where people are in cash
typically most Venture companies uh or
private Equity companies or even public
companies when they raise money uh they
have a certain amount of Runway and let
me talk about basically uh venture
capital and uh and Senior lenders you
know typically when companies raise 10
to 200 million dollars you know they're
in different Cycles they're in medical
device life science Technologies
software solar uh or you know energy
really doesn't matter but they have a
certain amount of Runway and you know to
the extent that after typically yeah 18
months to two years uh stuff happens uh
and it could be Market could be
competition uh it could be gross margin
uh it could be management it could be
strategy or any all the above but they
all revolve around the issue of cash uh
where ultimately people wanna need new
cash and the private Equity The Venture
Capital people or the banks are
basically saying no mas
uh and if I am going to give you more
money I have to have a leap of faith
belief that there's something there now
there's something called a Black Swan
which is always scary and you know um
I've alluded to the fact in a couple of
writings that the Black Swan shows up
every now and then and then there's a
Tipping Point well you know we're in a
Black Swan right now we're in an
atypical situation we have oil we got
Iran we got China we got interest rates
we've got what's going on in Europe
Ukraine
there are all these things that are
happening that sort of create havoc and
if you noticed a couple days ago uh you
know in England the bank uh you know did
something with their own uh the bank did
something with their own uh Banks and
trying to make sure that the balance
sheets were solid and they you know they
made them buy back you know some bonds
so the the issue about why things happen
it's you know it's it's Market it's
competition but it's also timing and
this happens probably every four to six
years and if you go back to history then
the numbers work you know I lived
through the 70s I remember 72 when the
market was you know really crashed and
then we had those oil lines and then
people got better than 78 you had the
oil lines then Reagan came in you had 19
interest rates then you had 87 when the
market blew up then you had you know 92
uh when a lot of the uh uh investment
Banks had a problem then he had 2001. so
you know this stuff happens so the real
issue you know why companies succeed and
why companies fail uh and I'm going to
give you a couple of reasons but I'll
always end up with cash really relies on
um the what I call the board of
directors responsibility to hold senior
management responsible and accountable
and that's my biggest gripe over the
years as a CEO investment banker
investor you know operator crisis
manager you know typically you you want
to see you know companies have strategic
plans tell me what's going to happen and
you know and then monitor it and see
what you did either you're going to get
here's the goal for the next three
months and then what happened
uh
one of the big issues is what I will
call the lack of financial controls not
saying they aren't there
but people uh you know uh when things
are well everything is good when things
started getting challenging you start
looking and you find all the loopholes
and one of the things that I totally
recommend people to do from a cold
startup to no matter how your business
is is to do Bottoms Up go forward
financial planning you know let me tell
you what Bottoms Up means you go through
and you look at your people you look at
your expenses you look at the realistic
uh you know sales projections you look
at the cost of goods you know Etc
um when I see sales numbers as an
example on forecasts I always question
tell me about the sale I mean you got
revenue that turns into Cash how long
when but really what is the architecture
with sale meaning I make a sales call on
you Michael
you're going to take time to make a
decision could be one month three months
once you make that decision I gotta ship
the product once I ship the product you
got to install it once you install it I
gotta get paid you know and it's a cycle
in there and typically you know a lot of
the projections are way too aggressive
and you know you look at all the
companies that have gone through in the
you know in the technology world uh you
know you look at meta as an example you
look at solar you look at energy uh you
know some of this is real some of this
is Puff one of the things that's
happened uh and Bill Gurley is a real
good proponent of this uh at Benchmark
is you know you gotta hold people
responsible accountable and you got to
do financial planning from the bottoms
up it's that simple it's not magic uh
and uh you know the same skills and
disciplines that you had in 1950 1960
1980 2020 are the saying that you need
all along and it's basically people have
to live through it because it's hard
it's like it you know my my grandson is
now 14 and you try to lead and teach
your grandson and your grandson is
telling your grandfather don't bother me
I'm gonna learn to myself
you have to learn it yourself and and
we're going through one of these Cycles
now that uh you know I think is going to
get a lot worse for it gets a lot better
I don't know if that answer your
question or yeah I know this one let's
so let's let's dive into a little bit I
talked a little bit about you know Board
responsibility holding Senior Management
accountable he talked about you know
cashes Kings and different things that
perhaps Senior Management and you know
should do and in these times what what's
what's happening right now is as you see
it so you know if we're looking at
different companies today in a different
Senior Management that maybe listening
to this or considering their own
situations what no what are some ways
that you're thinking about this that are
useful from from your vast experience
that that would allow for a company to
come out on top rather than fail at
these situations
well look for the first thing is you got
to be realistic and move your ego aside
we're in totally atypical times as we
have been in 2001 and 2008 as an example
which means it's far to project what's
going to happen you know on a go forward
basis first thing you look at is you
look at your people and you look at your
cost of doing business that's why you
see all these cutbacks coming in the
companies because people are top heavy
so it's easy to manage against costs you
look at what you got you look at your
Delivery Systems you look at the
production aspects you know you put
performance Milestones out there Etc so
cost is one aspect
revenue is always the toughest and it's
you know everybody's talking about one
first quarter or second quarter
projections come out they're going to be
changed and down or they don't know uh
and you know I would always incur being
error on the side of cautiousness and
conservativism in the revenues because
it's always better to beat something and
say I beat it rather than you know look
what happened why you know try to
explain the myths
but that you know they all relate to
cash because ultimately you need enough
to get through the process of the timing
of whatever the Black Swan The Tipping
Point the changes economic situations
cultural situations Etc and I I just
come back to it because you know in my
age you know you hear about uh North
Korea shooting off rockets and you hear
China closing its Gates and you hear all
the stuff about going on Ukraine and
should we support them and do we go to
war and you know it it it's real hard so
you have to have enough to weather the
storm and you know one does not know
when the storm ends so you be
conservative you manage on a monthly to
quarterly basis you say here are my
objectives
um both on a sales operational strategic
cost standpoint and let's see what
happens and the realistic and this is
where the challenge comes through
um I've been through four gender
Generations now of venture capital
people and two or three of bankers
and also where the CEOs are the CEOs are
getting younger and if you haven't been
through this you're too optimistic you
know you got to listen to some gray hair
or no hair and say be conservative it's
okay you're not going to get the rocket
right away because it isn't four years
ago when interest rates were flying and
everybody was making a ton of money Etc
so it's the it's it's the learning
experience and this is where I always
you know and it's easy because I'm an
outside guy that comes in and sees the
stuff uh I always look at the board and
as the board holding people responsible
and accountable and part of the investor
group that's out there they have so many
things going on that they don't have to
tie into either nurture or follow up if
you find the better companies and the
better Equity sponsors they're spending
more time with their portfolio companies
and they're working with them to you
know give them the guidance they need uh
and um uh you know we'll we'll see what
happens I mean this is these are you
know perilous times and we'll get
through them there's no question we get
through it the question is how much do
you have to bleed and how much do you
have to prepare you know Etc
one of the next things that's going to
come down is when you start slashing and
burning when you when you have to cut
back and when I get at the situations
when I look at companies
you always have to be concerned about
the human nature of people I mean people
need jobs people need to know survive so
you have responsibilities to your
shareholders you have responsibilities
to you the the people who work for you
but you also have responsibilities to
you know the you know General economic
environment
um so you have to see what happens the
other thing is you know when you look at
government one can look at whether or
not all the uh government uh subsidies
that have come out over the past three
or four years make sense or not
and you know look you have to have
sensitivity that people need to survive
and everything else but on the other
side there needs to be balance
um and history repeats itself we're
gonna go 5 000 years and you have all
these Empires that go up and down and
you know the United States now is what
250 whatever whatever the number is
years when 1776 200
42 years
uh old and if you look at previous uh
you know uh error errors you know we're
a little late in that cycle and we gotta
you know make sure that we take care and
understand you know the balance the
economic versus the social versus the
realistic
so for young entrepreneurs that are
building their companies and then you
know part of the consideration is how do
you bring on the right people to help
you grow as a company reached out
hockey's to growth optimize for your
product your error et cetera it sounds
like what you're saying here throughout
the and the sentiment that I hear is
that this is not enough there's
complexity that you need to understand
to withstand storms to go through with a
lot of respect dignity and part of that
is is is creating a cohesive group
around you that is going to hold you
accountable and will advise you on how
to you know change strategies when
needed how do you how do young
entrepreneurs like myself starting out
Ventures you know perhaps you know see
the series a stages think through these
Concepts in a mature way and create an
environment around us that that allows
us to nurture these situations and to
succeed with them
if I had answers to that question I'd be
really good it's a tough well you are
good that's why I'm asking you
so there are two issues that you deal
with
you have to feel comfortable with people
that you're either mentoring you or
giving you guidance and that you have
confidence in and as the CEO you have to
move your ego aside a little bit then
now you're running a company you raise
some money and you're in a hot market
and be able to listen
listening is very very hard at all
levels okay so if you find that person
and that mentor you know and it's only
one or two people that you really want
to bounce things off of I mean you can
have a board you can talk but you need a
mentor and you need somebody to talk to
that gives you the Comfort not to say
here you're right but to say have you
thought about these things to stimulate
Newt and not to give you the answers to
stimulate you into a dialogue
the second thing is you gotta hire and
train good people
um
people that are not yes people
that will tell you what's wrong what's
right people that will come to you and
say Michael here's the problem and
here's how I look to solve it I'd like
you to think about it
I remember uh I ran a uh 250 million
dollar company in the 70s in the
technology World wow and one of the
things I learned
um a long long time ago
is you hire strong people
who can challenge you
and not afraid to challenge you and
stimulate you and come up and say to you
because as I was going on the way up
from a branch manager regional manager
vice president you know president
reporting of somebody else
I always when something happened said
let me share with you what the problem
is and what I am going to do to solve
the problem
I'm coming to you with a solution and
you at least have developed confidence
in me that I can you know be able to
work through the situation now you may
agree or disagree because if you're
higher up in a chain but a hiring strong
and capable people is not necessarily
easy the second thing is is that in
today's world and a lectured at Stanford
and a couple of other places and I see
all the mbas go through the school and
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
and raise money
my recommendation is go get a job make a
sales call
go down in the manufacturing plant close
an order find out what it is to collect
accounts payable play with the numbers
to see what sales look like make some
sales projections
and it's not for everybody but I think
it's for most people because it's the
few that are really you know out there
that may get lucky but there also could
be good they could be the entrepreneurs
but learning and getting a job to me is
extremely you got to come from somewhere
I came from the IBM Corporation I'm
proud of that in the 1960s they were
King they were Apple
um
and they will Google whatever you know
in each each year Generations you have
people you know where you come from you
got to come from some place so that
that's something I'd strongly recommend
to entrepreneurs
um and you know and and find those
people uh again that have you know good
strategic advice for you as well
uh don't be afraid to make a decision
uh and if it's wrong you admit it uh and
you say here's what I did and here's
what I'm going to do to solve the
problem at whatever level
and that's that's not easy uh but you'll
learn about it uh because you have to
yeah and it sounds like you need to
surround yourself with people that are
going to give you that feedback to
sounds like what you're mentioning he's
not he's not he's not trivial
for anybody to do and you mentioned this
you know listening is hard on all levels
right and so it sounds like part of the
process as you're also growing I'm not
showing his leaders to
surround yourself with people that will
lead you accountable to these traits and
these qualities right
go into a meeting or how many I'll turn
around how many meetings have you been
in where the lead person sits and talks
and pontificates tell you how good it's
going to be and what their thoughts are
and doesn't really ask questions okay
think about that the next time you go in
there and go into a meeting where
somebody would say Okay I want to do
this but Jim Jane John Pamela what do
you think how do we go about this the
person that asked the questions is
really the true leader okay uh uh and
I've been in both types you know you go
back and then the guy's the expert or
the woman's the expert they're not
okay it's a team effect in life yeah I
love that and it sounds like um in these
in these crazy times what it sounds like
now everybody keeps talking about you
know the crazy times we're at but what I
think one of it one of the key elements
that I'm leaving this with
is saying it's a cycle and yes it's
because no but it's always crazy times
and I told we will survive and then and
then it'll repeat itself in in some
different way shape or form and and it's
it's good leadership that sustains over
time and you know we have a lifetime of
of uh of entrepreneurial adventures and
every person has so many different
experiences that
yeah go ahead I started off with a
comment that my grandmother told me way
back when
the more things change the more they
stay the same the same because it's a
cycle yeah it's just reality it's life
it happens you just accept it and for
those people that can get and want the
edge and they can listen
and understand I love it you know
yeah Stephen I I really really want to
appreciate your time again
I can't believe you know taking a no
they four Decades of experience uh
putting it into 20 minutes is impossible
and so I'm already looking forward to
our third episode to slowly slowly
uncover the pieces but this was a very
very enjoyable time for me and leaving
me thinking about my own leadership the
leadership of others around me my role
in their Journey the people that I'm
surrounding my myself with my journey
and so thank you very very much Stephen
and stay safe and stay healthy and uh
I'll give you one last thought please
remember if you are the CEO
you are responsible and accountable to
take care of your people
okay too many people say I'm going to
take care of myself you take care of
your people you will be taken care of
right I love that very very important
it's all about people buddy Michael you
you're the best thank you God bless you
and uh see you thank you very much